she's done a lot of smart things but I
mean I think the punchline is three
years that's a big ship yeah I mean it
depends on how you look at it but I
would say that's enough time in year one
year two you're unwinding a lot of
things I think I think Wall Street based
companies have it a little bit different
that you know the truth is you're
playing in a game this channel you're
playing in a game of 90 day terms I mean
if if I got to run Yahoo when Marissa
took over and I had it off of Wall
Street and had my life to run it I would
be doing a lot different behavior and I
think the pressure of what Wall Street
wants hurts a lot of these CEOs to do
short term behavior and so it's harder
for me to judge because I don't look at
the Wall Street CEO the same way I look
at as pre-ipo CEO but three years is a
lot of time now Verizon is proceeding
with a bid I mean let me give you an
example and I apologize in that three
years Marissa could have tried to buy
snapchat for four billion dollars twenty
four months ago that could have worked
possibly highly doubt that Evan Spiegel
would have said yes you're right and so
like and there's those things but I mean
I you know I always think that when
you're in full control you can do things
and so yeah I mean I think the results
are results results I'm a big believer
in the market as the market is the
market and meritocracy it rains but I'm
also not naive that
stockholders and the game you're playing
dictate some of those outcomes
well now Yahoo is for sale though she
still believed she could turn it around
if she had more time I can't lay more
time and I agree with her that's a big
mission these are big companies the
thought that you know I think of private
equity seven year terms or on Wall
Street three years these are big
companies like it'd be nice if they can
have ten years to prove it but you don't
right so Verizon is proceeding with a
bid yes is that the right thing for
Yahoo and Verizon and for Marissa is
this is this the ride no I mean look I
never really I'm not gonna come on this
show with the people that are watching
it ever cry for CEOs of Fortune 500
companies they always do okay you know
whether they win or lose where there is
not a lot of meritocracy is once you're
able to achieve a CEO status whether you
did a good job or a bad job you tend to
get paid quite well so I'm not I don't
know if it's good to me i IV Marissa
from afar I don't know her
as pretty strong actually and so I think
for her own operation wants and needs an
ego and you know feelings it might not
be good because she probably wants to
see it through Verizon I think this is
maybe doubling and tripling down on the
things that a well has brought to their
table as far as Yahoo I don't know it's
such a convoluted situation I said you
know you have the new draft this is
where I would say Marissa maybe left
something on a table again without
knowing if she could or couldn't do this
when when you need to break out you
can't go safe you have to be aggressive
and tell her was a big play as an early
investor in Tumblr and I was happy about
that so those are things you need for
Verizon it feels right because I do
think that some of the AOL content
things within the pipes that they're
trying to create have brought them value
and I do think the individual pieces of
Yahoo potentially could be quite
valuable was tumblr really the right bet
though I mean tumblr no tumblr was no
tongue no no tumblr was the wrong bet it
was the right kind of bet tumblr ended
up being the wrong bet because even at
the time they did it was probably wired
even I was a little disappointed because
I thought there was more room to go
tumblr missed their opportunity to go to
mobile the way they needed to a year or
two earlier and and so I would say no it
wasn't the right bet because but it was
the right kind of method